hello in this video i explain
what a regression analysis is and
give you an overview of the
different types of recession and
with that we start right
away a regression analysis enables you
to conclude or predict another variable based on one or more variables
, we say  you want to
find out what has an influence on
a person's salary for this you could take,
for example, the highest
educational qualification the
weekly working hours or the age of
a person you could now investigate
whether these three variables have an influence
on a person's salary
if yes if they do  if that is the case then
you can predict a person's
salary by showing the person's highest level of
education the number of hours worked each
week and the
person's age the variables that duh
want to infer is so the one you
want to predict is called the dependent
variable or k  criterion
the variables you use to predict
the are called independent variables
or protectors
two objectives can be pursued with regression
analysis you can measure the
influence of one or more
variables on another variable
or predict a variable based on
other variables
so that you can predict these two  areas get a
better feeling let's look at
examples again
let's start with measuring the
influence of one or more variables
on another one i could be
interested in research work
what influences
children's ability to concentrate i.e.
whether it can be
proven  that there are parameters that influence
children's ability to concentrate
positively or negatively
but you are not
interested in predicting children's ability to concentrate
or you could investigate whether the
educational level of the parents and the place of
residence have an e  This area has an influence on the
future educational level of
children. This area is therefore very interesting for
research and is
widely used in the
social and
economic sciences  long a
patient stays in the hospital
based on the characteristics of the
future patient such as age,
reason for the stay and
previous illnesses you want to know how
long this person is likely to stay in the
hospital based on this
prediction bed planning can then be
optimized or as the operator of
a  online shops are you very
interested in which product a person is
most likely to buy? would
you then like to suggest this product to the visitor in order
to increase the turnover of the online shop?
a revision is also used
here now, of course, there are still
different types of de  r recession
analysis but these are not difficult to understand
so let's start right
away with recession analysis, a distinction is made between
simple linear recession
multiple linear regression and
logistic regions
in simple linear
regression you only use one independent
variable to access the dependent
variable  close by example where we want to
predict a person's salary
we use only one variable either
whether the person has studied or not
the weekly hours worked or
a person's age
but only one variable is
used at a time multiple linear
regression uses multiple independent
variables  used to infer the dependent
variable
so you use the highest level of
education the weekly
hours worked and a
person's age to infer salary so the
difference between the simple
linear regression and the multiple the
seamstresses r  recession is that in
one case only one independent variable
is used and in the other case
several independent variables are
used both have in common that the
dependent variable metro bosses
are metric variables, e.g. a
person's salary, height, shoe size
or, for example, electricity consumption
Contrast this with logistic regression logistic recession
is used when you are a categorical
dependent variable for example if
you want to infer whether a
person is at risk of burnout or not
always if you answer yes no
you use logistic
recession i.e. at the line region  is the
dependent variable metric in the
logistic recession is the
categorical whenever a dependent
variable answers yes no
a logistic repression is used
a person buys a product yes or
no is a person healthy or sick
a person chooses a certain party j  a
or no
and so on and immediately in all
cases it doesn't matter which level the
independent variable these can be
either nominal original or metric
as I said the scale level of the
dependent variable can be in all three
cases so in the simple line in
the multiple linear  and in the case of the
logistic recession either be metrically
original or nominal
the dependent variable is metric in the linear
case and in the case of the
logistic recession nominal or
original it should be noted that in the case of
nominal or original independent
variables the variables can classically
only have two characteristics, such
as gender  male and
female your variables have more than two
values ​​then you have to form so-called
dummy variables
for the ami variables i have a
video of my own which will be added in the course of the
playlist before i show you how you can
easily calculate a recession online
so a short repetition  it
is the simple linear regression
a question could be does the
weekly working hours have an influence
on the hourly wages of employees the
special feature is that we only have one
independent variable then
we have the multiple linear regression
have the weekly working hours and
the age of employees
an influence on  the hourly wage
here we have two independent variables
weekly hours worked and age and
then the logistical recession does the
weekly hours worked and the age
of
workers have an impact on the likelihood that they are
at risk of burnout yes or no here
a logistical recession is used and
now i will show you  how you
can easily calculate a reaction online
please go to date
up de click on the statistics calculator
and if you
want to use your own data simply click on
table teachers and copy your data
into this table
ic  h just use the example we
want to calculate a regression so
we just click on regression now
here we can assume what our
dependent variable is and what our
independent variable is depending on what
the carl level of dependent variable
is it will be either a linear or a
logistic government  calculated
we take, for example, the income as a dependent
variable and as an independent variable
the weight of a person and the age of
a person then a linear
regression is calculated and here below
you get the results you
get the model summary the
hannover and the coefficients in my
video for  linear recession I will
then go into more detail on how you can interpret the values
you can
also output the summary in
words,
but if you click on a categorical
variable, e.g. the location,
a logistic region is automatically calculated and you
get your results here again
g  anz important is only to note
that we have not proven causality
just because we
have calculated a regression is this not very
clear
just look at my next video
about the connection between
correlation regression and causality
otherwise the video will go to
simple multiples  linear regression
or the video about the logistic
back next I look
forward to seeing you again soon